boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakhyan
really excited to be
still in sioux falls south dakota we are
at the sioux falls school district's
instructional planning
center ipc
and there this is how we develop a
school district for 25 000
kids in this area of the southeast
corner of south dakota this is my
hometown as you know and we are are
sitting down with two people that are at
the forefront of developing out this
school district we have both dr theresa
boyson and dr brian maher joining us
thank you so much for coming on to the
show really appreciate it thank you
thank you thank you our pleasure thank
you thank you um and the backgrounds are
really great here teresa has been
working in the sioux falls school
district for 25 years she was the
principal at harvey dunn for 12 years
and then also taught
for multiple years before that third and
fourth grade right
and
um
and also taught sports as well
and has had a huge track record there uh
brian maher
was at kearney prior to being
superintendent here which is in nebraska
he was their superintendent for eight
years and now has been here three and a
half years with the sioux falls school
district as a superintendent and
teresa's assistant superintendent and
we're really excited to talk about
developing out a school district and all
of the nuance that goes into this
because it is
how do you mold the 25 000 minds into
our world how do you assess
what's the curriculum like what's you
know from the national level how do you
keep up with exponential technology
sioux falls is burgeoning in population
so we passed 190 million dollar school
bond so we'll be talking about that
really excited to unpack this with you
both thank you again
let's let's start um even before we talk
about molding 25 000 minds into our
world what sparked the fire under you to
care about education and kids
and yeah take turns
since i have the mic i'll go ahead and
start awesome
i i think for me it was uh really the
adults in my life
when i was a when i was young
i grew up very poor in a
small small nebraska town
and
really had some
some motivators for me who were teachers
and coaches
who
made me believe i could do more than i
really thought i could and that's kind
of my spark to get into education to be
able to do what they were doing
growing up poor when i looked at
teachers i thought gosh they make pretty
good living they can they can do well
and of course i think now our teachers
are
grossly underpaid yes but that was that
was a motivator for me to to
get me going and
get into the field of education
that's interesting because i believe
that most people that get into in
education have that same history you
have someone in your life that was
impactful for you
when you were younger with it in the
school district and i grew up
in the super school district and so
that's exciting for me
third through twelfth grade here
and the teachers that made an impact on
my life and
for me to pursue my education then come
back here and to see some of those
teachers again but then those watch the
students as they go through
and the impact that we can have on
education in our community
it's
a recurring theme that we've seen with
all the entrepreneurs and different
people we host on the show where they
say that mentorship has been such an
influence on their development and it's
also one of the biggest contributors to
success as well as having some sort of
mentors and influence that drove you to
care about this so
okay so now
you see yours within these within these
teacher roles and administrator roles
you've slowly been better and better
understanding about okay thousands tens
of thousands of children
well i mean we're talking you know
billions of kids around the world need
their need to be molded into society in
a way that they can be
fully actualized themselves contribute
to the collective how does one even go
through the process of dealing with the
25 000 school
student school district and figuring out
how to best assess make a curriculum
seems super complicated and hard to to
actually do
sure
uh i think when you look at it in that
context that very broad context it is
super hard and really tough to do in
fact as you're asking that question i'm
going oh my gosh i don't know if i'm cut
out for this
i think what you what you do really is
you figure out what can i do
right now yes as you were as you were
formulating that question one of the
things that came to my mind was a
came from a book that i read on john
wooden who was a famous college
basketball coach
at ucla and
one of the things in his book that he
said was
it's what you learn
after you know it all
that really matters
i think there have been several times in
my life where i thought i knew it all
and i've learned so much after that
now what i've now what i think i realize
is i know more today than i knew
yesterday and hopefully i'll be able to
say that tomorrow and next week and next
month and that's really i think where we
are as a school district too what do we
do
what do we know now and what are we
doing now
but really how are we developing the
minds of kids to think because it's very
clear now if you look at history that
we're not we're not preparing kids
for the world that i live in just as the
teachers that i had
didn't develop me to live in the world
that they lived in but they did develop
in me
an ability to think
and an ability to think critically so
that i could handle those issues that
came my way
whether that's a
society societally but politically
whatever realm those issues came in and
i think that's our charge and
that's an evolving charge so we don't
ever have the answer but hopefully we
continually
put together an answer
and that is um
my title is
academic achievement and so within that
everything curriculum and assessment and
so in the sioux falls school district
when you look at we have pre-k 12
25 000 students how do we
assess what we're doing
and make changes so the students are
college and career ready and
it starts in kindergarten it starts
before kindergarten and the challenges
that our students come in with the
student we have to meet their needs at
the door
look at where every student is if i have
a classroom of 25 students i know i have
25 different needs because all students
are different and that teacher has a big
job of being able to build that
relationship with them know where they
are academically emotionally socially
and develop all those skills so we have
a well-rounded child at the end and then
when we look at the other end college
and career ready
continually to develop pathways and look
at the businesses in our local community
and how we can work together to support
the businesses and
feed
their need also but also have that
student be able to
take courses that are relevant for them
but also feels their passion so it's a
big charge but again continually
examining what we're doing
what's working what's not working look
for those bright spots and build on
those
there was two things there that just
really drove me one from each of you
with just it's almost like there's a
torch that's being passed on from the
previous generations to us now and then
now it's our turn to figure out how to
add more to the torch and figure out
where to keep pushing education forward
and then also this this i the idea that
when even when you get a classroom of
students
you have a diverse population of minds
and
and just even dealing with not only
different learning styles but also
different
parental involvements in education uh
different socioeconomic statuses
there's so much of that of that nuance
where some kids are reading already at
multiple levels beyond the classroom and
there's some kids that are still a level
maybe behind in reading so how do you
teach as a teacher this is extremely
difficult to
be able to do
so okay so let's let's talk about the
the the
how does a curriculum build how did how
do we figure out so the torch was kind
of passed with the curriculum it's been
developed over time and also how we
assess but then there's like the
national
standards and testing that have to
happen so we're always trying to prep
for the national testing and then but
then also there's the exponential
technology that we're adding into the
picture so how does that all play out
okay um so when you think about
curriculum
of course we look at the national
standards and the state standards and
how they feed into that and we have a
process for reviewing that curriculum
and those standards and
purchasing a curriculum that's going to
meet the standards meet the students
needs
and provide the ability for the teachers
to add their own flavor into that also
to meet the diverse needs of all our
students when we look at
your comment of we have students that
are reading beyond our grade level or
below our grade level
providing the teacher supports and
avenues to be able to differentiate that
learning for those students that's
really important
and to be able to meet all their needs
because we know
that within that one classroom you have
multiple levels whether it's math
writing reading
all of those subjects
we do have those different levels
the state assessments and the national
assessments that we're required to take
our curriculum
when by meeting the needs by meeting
those standards feeds into that
assessment so if we're using
the materials that we have purchased in
the curriculum writing and the testing
that we do within house
it does feed those very naturally so
it's a good process we have a great team
that
helps we have teacher input on all those
committees and
writing in-house assessments we have
district assessments
that
align with our curriculum align with the
state and national standards to give us
benchmarks along the way so we're not
waiting till the end to see if our
students make the mark we're assessing
that along the way and so we can make
changes as needed and we know from one
group to the next we do need to make
changes so it's a great process it's a
great school district that really does
value the feedback of the teachers we
look at the assessments along the way to
make adjustments in the curriculum to
make sure we're hitting the mark for our
kids so they have they can you know we
have ap classes our act scores are above
the state national and it's because we
believe it's because of that process
sure
i i think it hits the mark we'll see
to oversimplify meta-analysis done by
john hatty
planning engagement and feedback that's
the learning cycle
our best teachers no matter what
curriculum they're they're putting in
front of students
no matter what content they're in charge
of no matter what age of the students
that they're in charge of
planning engagement and feedback our
best teachers are great planners
they're great at engagement
and they give quality feedback if you're
missing one of those pieces
the whole
curriculum development educational cycle
bogs down and it doesn't matter if
you're in charge of
50 students
or 25 000 students or 125 000 students
if you can master planning the
engagement and feedback
you will be doing right by the kids that
we serve
and that's our that's our challenge
every day
um
when as you were speaking i was also
hearing this importance of feedback and
then you gave this
planning engagement feedback cycle
and then there's all of the importance
of adding in the right
sort of you have ap classes you have
these different
you have
how does one even deal with a national
assessment but also a state assessment
and i really enjoyed the way that
you know the if you have if you have a
teacher that's doing a really good job
planning assessing uh engaging and then
assessing
planning engaging and then getting
feedback
that that process is
just it does seem like kind of like it's
a really good gold standard
differentiation i gave an analogy
earlier i gave a little talk earlier
about john wood and i'll go to another
sport and another coach who talks about
his son brian's son is a
kicker for cowboys and you like football
a lot you know i i did and i still do
still do yeah but but i think that the
best coaches
there's a lot of leadership qualities
that you can take for them that is
generalized beyond the sport i'll give
an example of tom osborne growing up in
nebraska you know
tom osborne was a head football coach at
the university of nebraska for a number
of years and he talked about more than
winning in one of his books and really
his point was this
that if you if you don't worry about
winning and i'll use the the analogy
there that i don't worry about what
those state and national standards are
then they're important so don't i don't
want to just dismiss them
but if i don't worry too much about what
they are rather i worry about
blocking and tackling
i'm going to win enough that's
interesting if i worry about the
fundamentals of the game of football and
i get exceedingly good at those
fundamentals in football i'm going to
win a lot of football games
i make i make that transference to
education and i think if we do enough
things right in terms of teaching kids
how to think critically
and all those things that dr boyson
talked about in terms of developing the
curriculum and all those things are
necessary
but if in the end we think about how do
we teach kids to think critically
those assessments are going to take care
of themselves how we perform on our
state national standards will all take
care of themselves if we think about how
we bring that individual along
it's kind of like planning engagement
and feedback it's that simple
and it's that complex it's hard to stay
focused
on those little things because we're
always getting the soup of the day
to come in and help with reading or help
with writing or help with math
and really what we want to do is make
make sure that we're teaching kids how
to think critically because they come to
us at all different levels you mentioned
poverty
if all of our kids came to us
at the same spot in terms of their
development
that the job would be easier now i would
contend it would be less fun
but it would it would be easier if we
get kids
who can't nearly read at grade level
as you mentioned and we get kids who are
reading multiple years ahead of grade
level in the same class how do we teach
them to read
but how do we teach them to be consumers
of that information and to think
critically
that's the that's the complexity that
we're dealing with that's the challenge
that we deal with every day that part i
don't think has changed
since i was a kid yeah and i don't think
it will change for a long time yeah the
technology's changed tremendously along
the way yeah but
how do we think and how do we think
critically so that we can
consume and react to that information
that i think is our chief charge and i
don't know how you assess that
okay so as we talk about curriculum and
assessment how does a school district
figure out how to
stay up at the cutting edge of all the
exponential technologies you have
programs like code to the future which
is really exciting getting kids playing
with mit scratch-based programming
language so these
sort of way they're kind of the cutting
edges of getting kids involved in stem
education you were at the stem
summit this summer this summer um
in dc and so tell us tell us about that
well
that was really exciting to be a part of
number one uh just the fact that it's in
dc and the energy that goes with that
but also seeing our our country saying
we're we're going to take a
a forward stance in this whole stem
conversation so that was uh that was
excellent just to be a part of that and
uh not only
not only was it
the folks from education there but you
had business and industry there as well
as obviously government there so those
are those are three entities that don't
always play nicely together and we were
all there under a common under a common
theme so that was good
to your question of how do we stay on
the cutting edge
i think that's a question that we always
are asking ourselves how do we stay on
the cutting edge and
how do we stay on the cutting edge
without becoming
just gimmick
just
adopting something because it looks good
i'm reminded years ago of how we had
some distance learning labs
put together and we were very proud of
this room because it looked
21st century back in the early 1990s and
and
one of my colleagues said to me how
often do you use this room with your
students
and just almost took me to my knees
because we didn't use it
nearly to the capacity that we could
have used it so what do we what do we do
to stay on the forefront that really
impacts kids
that's something that i think that that
we're always thinking about
how so how do we do it uh for us i would
say there are a couple of ways number
one
we're the only school district in the
state of south dakota that's part of a
national group called the league of
innovative schools
of promise
and we we are with like-minded districts
around the nation
twice a year trying to figure out
number one what technology is out there
but how does that take technology impact
critical thinking for the students that
we serve and and how do we do that
i can tell you the folks here
they
break into hives when i go to those
meetings because i always come back with
ideas that i want them to implement so
but but i think it's
through being involved in those think
tank think tanks and getting out of the
day-to-day
grind if you will
in in being a part of
that that national movement on how do we
improve education nationally
and we do it by improving education in
sioux falls we do it by improving
education locally
there's your thoughts on the exponential
technology sure yeah um you spoke to
code to the future and code of the
future is a coding that we do with
k through 8 students now
and it really has
helped students to think differently
about
how
what their careers could look like but
what else is out there and when dr maher
talked about
teaching students to think critically
and persevere that really quoted the
future really has helped
students do that we see leaders in those
classrooms who might not have been
leaders before but now it's another
avenue for them to shine
and so that's been a great thing
for sioux falls you know avionics
robotics all of those
technologies that we have and then how
do we use
just our everyday chromebooks that we
have in the hands of second through
twelfth graders and to make sure it's
it's not just an addition or replacing
paper but how do we use it differently
so they're not just a consumer of
technology but a user of technology and
so continually to support our
instructional coaches to and our
instructional coaches support our
teachers
to look at things differently
using an lms a learning management
system within their classroom to model
that platform of
online learning really looking at micro
credentialing for our staff and so
that's where they can do personalized
staff development for them but they can
do that on their
at a time that works for them in an area
that works for them that we
support and we know that's good quality
professional development so really
looking outside the box of
that traditional learning but that
traditional staff development for our
sioux falls district staff
stem is such an important field that is
just exploding across every single
industry so to have
a
a focus on that and a focus on just
cutting edge use of technology in the
classrooms in ways that both maximize
the the child's ability to critically
think but also minimize their
distractions actually brian when you're
mentioning earlier the in the
interesting analogy of playing a game of
football and getting really good at the
basics of whatever sport or whatever
even
potentially drawing or art or whatever
the coding what are the basics that
there's these the distractions come in
as well and so to
to block out the distractions is so
important especially with
the development of a cutting edge
technology because it can be used for
for distraction as well
let's talk about the explosion of the
population in sioux falls and how that's
affecting
class sizes in the schools it was so
cool to read about the 190 million
dollar school bond that was passed for
the sioux falls school district here
the could that's going to fund the
construction of a new high school a new
middle school a new elementary school
and then uh do
renovations on additional educational
infrastructure and that is
that's so exciting to be you know to
think about especially because uh
there will be a
it's not only that there the city cares
a lot about the economic development of
of the city as well as the minds of the
children but also that it's great to see
that this class sizes will hopefully
decrease so that
a teacher will have maybe
25 children instead of 32 or whatever so
they'll have
they can focus maybe more on each uh
individual child's development so
there's a there's a lot of good that's
going into this the school itself uh you
you're
there's so much nuance that goes into
this but the the architect uh sure of
the new schools you hopefully have more
natural light coming in more of an
ambiance of maybe some nature
involvement in it so that's uh this is
all really cool stuff and we're excited
to learn from you about what this
process has been like teach us about it
sure
sure well the first thing i'd say about
a bond if you have if you have anybody
watching this and they're trying to
figure out where to relocate
sioux falls south dakota might not jump
to your to your list of places to be
but if you have kids and you need them
educated i know i'm biased
but i can't think of a better place than
sioux falls south dakota and i'll offer
this for evidence
we just asked the
the folks who live in this school
district we asked them to raise their
taxes yeah that's what we asked them to
spend more money
and those things those votes
are always 50 50. i mean they're close
to
if you pass it it's by the
hair your chinny chin chin you know i
mean it's
our yes vote
on that on that bond issue so we said
will you vote yes to raise your taxes
yeah
85.46 of the voters yeah said yes that's
phenomenal that's huge i think it's
unprecedented
and until somebody tells me it's not i'm
going to go with that
that's amazing to have 85 out of 100
voters more than 85 out of 100 voters
say yes do that to me that doesn't speak
to
to me or or to us
but it speaks to the commitment to
education in this city
and it and the folks in this community
understand that this isn't about
k-12 education this isn't about ending
at the age of 18. this is about
taking this city and continuing to have
it grow and continuing to have a
workforce that allows it to grow
that the the fact of the matter is we're
we're preparing
students like you allen who are going to
go make their mark well beyond the city
of sioux falls as well as hopefully
have have their mark in in the city of
sioux falls but
that's kind of my
my commercial but it's all based in fact
on
there i know this there isn't a better
place to be a superintendent of schools
than the sioux falls school district
to have that support is incredible
and and then now it's a matter of now
how do we how do we make sure that the
trust that was placed in us
manifests itself in quality outcomes for
the students of this of this city
that's our that's our goal that's kind
of what we're talking about yeah yeah
this is a multi-year project it's
looking like until potentially three
four almost four years probably probably
four probably four or five years before
we see everything come to fruition
probably
three years before we actually have a
new high school and a new middle school
built and and we're moved into them but
in the meantime we're we're really
engaging folks from the community to
help us make sure that the design is
what we want it to be and i don't mean
just from an aesthetically pleasing
perspective but from a functionally
relevant
perspective so that again we're trying
to
we're gonna we're gonna live in this
building for a long time
so we don't want it just to be ready to
go three years from now but how can it
be how can it be relevant 30 40 50 years
from now yeah for educating the kids
that are going to to come along at that
point in time
thoughts
part of that work on like dr maher
referenced is making that building
useful now and in the future and that's
that architect and the design team has
really been instrumental with us
and engaging us in
what does education
what will the facilities
do now but then in the future and how
does it look different than a roosevelt
a lincoln or a washington our current
high school models and so that's a lot
different
and it has been really fun to dream big
and to look at other options out there
and so we really are in those initial
phases with architect and the design
team to see
where we can go but then how's our
teaching philosophies match that also so
lots of challenges
exciting or challenges or opportunities
to
look at that education system and what's
it mean for our students in terms of
stem and
entrepreneurship and all of those
opportunities or those pathways for kids
yeah
i i remember watching
a video where you were
discussing
with
some press about well there will be a
certain time that we are able to deal
with the architects and we're getting
proposals and we are also looking to
find a really important name that sticks
on the school that it's that indicates
that we care about the future
we
are thinking about the all these
different layouts and how the school can
stay relevant over time
the locations of building them this is
this is very very difficult to be able
to figure out how to actually deal with
the developing school district in a
population that's that's increasing in
size
so
what i have been then because when i
when we were first talking i ended up
writing a very little bit
uh a blog post about how i thought it
was it was interesting how when we were
speaking that i learned from you that
well
shouldn't we really be thinking about
what is across the street from these
buildings
because if there is a you know if there
are archaic sort of
of businesses across the street then
then the kids may go and eat unhealthy
and they may not be as inspired as if
there were maybe healthier food options
exercise options art options business
options or entrepreneurship options
science options
and that's why one of the reasons why
this high school is being built next to
the the career tech
academy and southeast tech and zeal
center for entrepreneurship and up in
that northwest corner and so so maybe
speak on on on some of the the
complexity that goes on with what we
were talking about but also the
importance of of how you are planning to
develop out the areas next to the to the
schools and how much involvement even
sioux falls school district has in those
decisions
i can speak to how do we
engage the careertech academy and
southeast tech with a new high school
because those are three of our entities
that um you know we're one of the unique
school districts where the
southeast technical institute is under
the support school district or a part of
the sioux falls school district so how
can we work with that
tech academy and our career at tech
academy to develop
courses for our students where they
can easily flow between the three of
them and then use the zeal center for
entrepreneurship that's right across the
street also yeah so
really looking at those pathways you
know a medical pathway we're working on
that a computer
cyber pathway we're working on that and
both
career tech academy and southeast tech
play into that and that would just be a
natural flow for though for that high
school but for our other three high
schools also and
just opportunities for students that
they hadn't
thought of before so and making sure we
can publicize that and get that
information into the family's hands but
also the students hands so they can take
full opportunity of that
i think maybe just to extend on that too
we have a we have a great relationship
with our business community that plays
into
that relationship with southeast
technical institute with the
the zeal center and opportunities that
we have to be nimble
rather than to take years to adapt to
what our community needs
maybe we can take months to adapt to
what our community needs whether that be
from a manufacturing standpoint or
remember whether that be from a business
startup standpoint we can be real nimble
into what our community
really needs that's that's number one
the the other thing i would say in terms
of the development we looked at a lot of
things in terms of where we would place
this high school
certainly the synergy that exists
with the technical institute right there
the career and technical education
academy right there the proximity to
those two
facilities
was a piece of it but from a very
practical standpoint we had to have
about 45 acres of land yeah and so to
find 45 acres of land in a developing
city is is sometimes difficult so there
was a practical piece there
and in terms of how will things develop
around
there
i don't know what our impact will be but
i think the biggest impact is the fact
that
we've said this is where we want a an
educational facility to exist
so now we'll see
how the area develops yeah certainly
there'll be
residential that will
develop there's already a lot of
residential developing out in the
northwest yeah tons of residential so
it'll be exciting it'll be it'll be fun
25 years from now to look back
to see how that did develop yeah
yeah
yeah i'll just be blunt about it i
really don't want to see mcdonald's and
a burger king on those corners i think
it's i think that's
way
archaic it's way
overdue to have uh a different sort of
uh style of of of of corners uh that are
developed in the suburbs of sioux falls
that it can potentially be a
um
a
a model
corner right over there where the new
high school is going to be it could be a
model corner where you see
healthy options for food you see um
you see
a center for art you see a an exercise
center and when the kids
every day drive past it their brand
recognition moves towards health and to
to
to tech and art instead of to
old
archaic technologies that and and
businesses it's very possible somebody
would sell you the land out there to
develop that
yeah i'm i'm i hope that
that
somewhat someone that's watching us from
the sioux falls community um
will will take on that initiative of
wanting to develop the land next to
those 45 acres and and take it in that
direction instead of um instead of
in the old
um
incumbent directions that we see
developing out on so many uh
corners of
of of of the developing areas of sioux
falls
so now this is this has been this
there's there's a lot that goes into
developing a school district and we were
only uh talking about you know really
the tip of of of everything it's so
difficult to get down to
all of the glacier that's located below
the water that that exists i mean
in in a short less than our conversation
to try and understand how a school
district works super tough
and we'll aim to do this again when we
come back to sioux falls and talk to you
more about what's going on do these
check-ins and and and build out
a better understanding for people about
what actually goes on within a school
district and how it grows
um
last thoughts on the way out
there's usually
one thing
that someone can
recommend that is maybe most profound
for
for students for for teachers for
parents
what is the one
thing that you can maybe say could
accelerate to turn into a habit
for a student for a teacher for a parent
what is that one habit that you think
could be developed
that could maximize the potential of
education in our world
you get to go first
oh so so
my my kind of my reaction
when i get something that's a real deep
question like that i go with all right
what what just popped into my mind two
things popped into my mind and i think
about my own development and neither of
these were natural for me
but both of them are commonplace for me
today
two things that i do on a regular basis
that i think have made a tremendous
difference in my life
and a tremendous difference in my
ability to think critically yeah which
is a theme you've heard me yeah go back
to time and time and time and again
today
one is um to meditate yes and to take
time to
to be reflective and
you there are a number of different ways
that that that can happen so i'm not
here to profess that there's one day one
way that's better than any other way
yeah but i can say for me
it's important and it's important daily
yeah and the second thing and i don't
know which of these i'd pick i'd
probably pick meditation if i could only
do one
uh but the other is to read yeah and it
did definitely to get yourself to think
by reading and to me it doesn't even
really matter what you're reading
whether it's self-help
or fiction i don't know that it really
matters
but i think it's important that you read
and as a
as a youngster growing up i'd much
rather be out shooting a basketball than
reading
and so reading wasn't something that was
natural for me
but i over time realized how important
it was for me and it has become
natural for me as a result of
understanding its importance
yeah those are so good
and i would go back to
what's important and
for me it's
is it reflection
meditation or time for exercise whatever
that looks like for you but that
reflection and taking time to reflect on
your day
and what worked what didn't work
what are you going to change and look
forward to
and you know right now information is so
readily available and making sure you
research your options and if we're
talking about kids listen to them take
time for them
show them let let them have time to
develop their passions
and
spend time with them because when you
spend time with your kids or whether
it's kids in your classroom
it comes back to you
and you develop those relationships so
taking that time is really really
important to develop
their interests
oh those were so good i love those
we
we frequently
talk about that just
how important it is to reflect how
important it is to
turn off the stimuli that we're
constantly taking in
and just breathe and be silent and go
inward for periods of time even a couple
minutes a day and what that does for our
development for physiology for
creativity for our gratitude that we
have
love and compassion
um and also of course just turning these
things into into into habits of passing
time with with our kids in the
development um so so good okay last
question what do you guys think is the
most beautiful thing in the world
i would say love
that whether it's love for another
person or love for your environment
and it's that passion that goes with it
so that that would be my answer is love
for each other
and the world and the environment
that's way too deep for me alan so i'm
going to go a whole different direction
here i'm headed tonight i'm going to get
on a plane i'm going to go to dallas
i'm going to watch the dallas cowboys
play in the playoffs tomorrow and the
most beautiful thing i can see this
weekend is made kicks
that's right dallas cowboys that's right
that's the most beautiful thing in my
life this weekend that's right
this weekend how about outside of the
playoffs in football it's it
probably is a as a grandparent maybe i
think the most beautiful thing is
watching the development
of
my own grandkids
and then try to transfer that to the
development that we're in charge of for
the for the kids in the city and really
and to to kind of see that natural
evolution and the iteration that is
that human development that's what i'm
committed to and that's what i think is
a beautiful thing yeah
wow this weekend it's made kicks it's
made kicks it's those long field goals
yeah even the short ones are so
important yeah yeah even short and so
important um wow what a pleasure this
has been thank you thank you thank you
dr boyson brian maher thank you so much
thank you guys both so much um thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we would love to hear from
you what would you think are the big
principles and points that we should be
discussing around molding children into
our world educating children developing
our school districts how can we best do
this around the world let us know about
what's going on in your communities in
your districts as well
and also build the future manifest your
destiny into the world everyone go build
create execute thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon
bye